tee
bg
me
みなさんこんにちは
北海道情報大学メディアデザイン専攻4年の福大健闘と申します
私は
このような
文字やイラストなどに動きが加わった
モーショングラフィックスという映像を作っています
この映像は私が今まで作ってきた映像を一つにまとめたものです
今日は
私が大学入学後どのように映像を作ってきたのかをお話ししたいと思っています
私は幼い頃からものを作るのが好きでした
高校3年生の進路を決めるときに
パン人の先生が北海道情報大学のパンフレット僕のところへ持ってきてくれて
情報大学のメディアデザイン専攻というところでデザインを学べると知りました
私は絵が下手でデザインなんてもちろんやったことなかったんですがもしかしたら私に
もかっこいいデザインを作ることができるかもしれない
そんな希望を持ってここ北海道情報大学に入学しました
しかし入学してすぐにデザインの難しさを痛感します
これは私が大学1年生の頃に作ったイタリアンレストランのショップカードを作ると
いう課題だったんですが
見ての通り思っていたようなかっこいいデザインを作ることができませんでした
そして周りには私より上手なデザインを作れる人がたくさんいました
私のデザインに対するモチベーションはどんどん下がり
大学1年生の終わり頃にはもうデザインを諦めていました
大学2年生になり
たまたまネットサーフィンをしていた時に
ニコニコ動画で見た
初音ミクの8に私は心を奪われました
パート
me
いいいいいい
ん
とてもかっこいいですよねー
この音と完全に毒気した映像の気持ち良さや
このデザイン私は惹かれました
それから映像制作に興味を持ち
僕が区で始めてみようと思いました
それが2012年の6月1日のことです
私はその日の夜に早速自宅で映像を作りました
その時の映像がこちらです
th
ana
ええええええ
はぁ
当時は知事のスキルがまったくなかったので
家にあったカメラを使ってこの映像を作りました
私はどんどん英語政策に夢中になりました
大学2年生の頃に受講していたプロジェクトトライアルという好機で私はファーぷと
いう男性用軽商品会社を企画しました
その時に作った映像がこちらです
トゥデイ
hal
ん
どうしてい
この時はとにかく映像を作るのが楽しくて
朝から晩まで常にエイドのことを考えて作っているような生活でした
ただ
スキルが全然なかったので
自分の作りたいようなカッコいい映像が作れず常にモヤモヤしていました
大学3年生になり
私は何か結果を出したいと強く思うようになりました
自身が欲しかったんです
そして私は
ギャッツビーの cm を作るというコンテストを見つけ
この映像を応募しました
see me
ame
ん
voodoo
ame
ん
このエゾは結局だねで
入賞できませんでした
当時の私はかなり自信があったので入賞できなかったときにとても落ち込みました
なぜこの映像は入賞できなかったのでしょうか
この映像コンテストではアイディアや企画の斬新さや面白さを求めていたんですが当時
の私は cg の技術にばかり夢中になっていて
アイディアや企画のことは全く考えてませんでしたそれがいけなかったんですね
そして私は気がつきました
技術ばかり勉強しててもダメなんだ
それからはもちろん技術も勉強するんですが
アイディアや企画のことをもっと考えるようになりました
それから少し経って
大学3年生の終わりごろに
twitter である方かな
ボーカロイドのミュージックビデオ作って欲しいと頼まれました
私は作った映像を youtube に公開していたのでそれをたまたま見て声をかけ
てくれたみたいです
こんなこともあるんですね
そして作ったのがキャラメルタルトという映像です
me
この映像を作ってニコニコ動画に投稿したところ
約5万回も観てもらうことができました
歌詞が若い子の恋愛をテーマにしたものだったので
最近の若い子は
スマートフォンや sns を使って恋愛しているんじゃないかと思い
このような映像を作りました
それが珍しかったみたいで動画のコメントでも新しいとか面白いと言ってもらえたので
私はとっても嬉しかったです
この時に改めて感じたのが
技術力の高さではなくて
アイディアや企画の
強さがあれば面白いと思ってもらえるので
このように映像を作っていこうと思いました
大学4年生になり
私はもう一人前になったつもりでした
しかし
ある日
同じゼミの女の子にこんなことを言われます
福田のつくで映像って
かっこいいんだけどなんかどっかで見たことがあるような感じだよねー
私はこの一言に結構腐ってきました
それまでは他の方が作った作品のカッコイイと思うところを真似したりそれに何か足し
たりして映像を作っていたんですがそれが自分の映像に表れていたんですね
この辺りから
今までにないような新しい映像を作りたいと思うようになりました
そしてこんな映像を作ってみました
voodoo
これは今年の北海道庁法大学の cm コンテストに応募した映像です
qr コードを
映像や cm に使っているものはいままでなかったので
qr コードをデザインしてさらにアニメーションさせてみました
またこんな映像も作りました
ています
me
ん
en
3 d cg の技術で髪の質感に挑戦したこの映像は
北海道映像コンテスト2014の学生どもんで優秀賞をいただきました
ありがとうございます
twitter で知り合った方と
こんな映像も作ってみました
お墓にプロジェクションマッピングしたんです
を畑に映像を投影するなんてまあとても不謹慎ですよね
もちろん発泡白で作った偽物です
このように色々試行錯誤して映像を作るんですが
なかなか自分のオリジナリティが出てきません
私は悩んだ結果
cg を使って映像を作ることが多かったので
他の表現手法も試してみようそう思いました
その時に試しに作ってみた手描きアニメーションがこちらです
ban
amaran
aname
どうでしょうか
私は少しですが
手応えがありました
もしかしたら
手書きのアニメーションを使って
個性的な映像を作ることができるかもしれない
そう思い私は大学4年間の集大成となれ
卒業制作で手描きアニメーションを作ることに決め
現在製作中です
最後になりましたが先ほど流れたテック製いっちゃあいうのオープニングムービーも私
が作りました
i am
tease
b 4
ています
私が
映像の制作に興味を持ったのは
たまたまニコニコ動画で見た初音ミクの映像でした
それからたくさん映像を作って
顔も知らないネット上のクリエイターとコラボレーションしたり
映像のコンテストで賞をいただいたり
来年の4月からは東京の映像制作会社で働けることにもなりました
インターネットにはまだまだいろいろな可能性があると思うので私はこれからももっと
勉強していきます
そして
インターネットにはたくさんのコンテンツがありますが
オリジナリティが大切だと思うので自分のオリジがオリジナリティについても深く追求
していきたいと考えています
これが私の考えです
ありがとうございました